i want to make a quick correction to the
last video where we introduced the
carboxylic acid videos and then we can
actually compare them in terms of their
relative stability and that one mistake
i did is when i named the ester all i
did is i named kind of the main carbon
backbone i didn't actually tell you how
how many carbons you have attached to
the oxygen over here acetate really just
refers to this part over here knowing
that it is bonded to or maybe i should
say it refers to this part over here but
you also have to specify how many
carbons you have over here so this
molecule that we drew over here is
actually methyl acetate
this is
methyl acetate or if you want its
systematic name it's
methylethanoate and this is where we get
the methyl from it is methyl
it is methyl ethanoa now with that out
of the way let's actually compare these
carboxylic acid
derivatives and i'll compare the
derivatives of acetic acid
so the first one we saw
was the amide acetamide
acetymide looks just like this
this is
acetamide
then the next one we looked at was the
ether and that's the one i just pointed
out the mistake on
so this was
this was
ethyl acetate so you have ch3 right here
this is where sorry this is methyl
acetate this is where the methyl part
comes from so this is
methyl
acetate and then we will compare that to
the anhydride version so this is acidic
anhydride let me do this in a new color
acetic anhydride looks like this
acetic
anhydride
looks just like that
acidic
acidic and hydride
acidic anhydride and finally
finally we had the we had the acetyl
chloride
acetyl
acetyl chloride
looked just like this
and of course these are all derivatives
of acetic acid which we drew at the top
of the last video which is right over
there acetic acid now let's think about
which of these may or may not be more
stable
and to think about it we're going to
think about any resonance structures
that these molecules might have so if we
first focus on acetamine
we know that nitrogen forms three bonds
and then has two extra electrons that
form
another lone pair and it's actually it's
actually electron rich because it's a
good bit more electronegative than the
hydrogens here and actually even a
little bit more and a reasonably more
electronegative than the carbon it's
attached to so you can imagine a
situation where
a nitrogen could donate an electron to
this carbon right over here and then
that carbon can let go of one of the
double one of the electrons in a double
bond with the oxygen and so it could go
back to the oxygen and you would have a
resonant structure
you would have a resonance structure
that would look like this
let me actually use the same colors
you would have a resonance structure
that would look like this this oxygen
just gained an electron up there
and actually let me draw the electron
well actually i'll just put the negative
charge do that elect do to that electron
and then we had
this bond right over here to
the nitrogen but the nitrogen just gave
an electron to this carbon right here
the carbonyl or what was the carbonyl
carbon and so now we have a double bond
over here
and the nitrogen just gave an electron
so it now has a positive charge but this
is a resonant structure of acetamine so
pretty stable pretty stable so this is
maybe i should even say quite stable so
this is quite
quite
quite stable now let's think about an
ether here and we could probably do
something fairly similar so if we think
about this ether here oxygen has
oxygen has two
two extra lone pairs it is more
electronegative than the things that it
is bonded to so it could do a very
similar thing to what this nitrogen did
it could give an electron
to this carbon right over here and then
that carbon can give back an electron to
this to the carbonyl oxygen to that
oxygen over there and so its resonance
structure
would look like this
it would have a resonant structure so
it's almost the exact same thing as as
what we saw with the amide
so it would have a resonance structure
this oxygen just gained electron now
we'll have a negative charge
this bond to the oxygen
is still there but this oxygen just gave
another electron formed another bond
with what was the carbonyl carbon it
actually forms a new carbonyl group if
you want to view it that way
and so it will look like this and this
oxygen gave away an electron so now it
has a positive charge so this is
seems like a pretty good resonance
structure so the question is which of
these two are going to be more stable
and the answer there really just comes
out of the periodic table if you look at
nitrogen and oxygen
if you look at nitrogen oxygen they're
right there they're both near the top
right they're both pretty
electronegative but oxygen is more
electronegative it is to the right of an
eye of nitrogen
so because oxygen is more
electronegative remember
electronegativity is just the tendency
to hog electrons how much do you like to
hog electrons oxygen likes to hog
electrons more than nitrogen likes to
hog electrons so it would be less likely
marginally less likely to give away an
electron than nitrogen would be so this
resonance structure is a little bit less
likely or you know when you think of it
probabilistically it's going to happen a
little bit less frequently than this
resonance structure so this one right
here this is going to stabilize it less
so this is going to be a little bit less
stable than the amide so this is if we
call this quite stable i'll just say
this is just this is just
just stable over here
now let's think about what's going to
happen with the anhydride the anhydride
once again we have an oxygen right here
we have an oxygen right here it's got
its spare electrons it's more
electronegative than the things that
it's bonded to so
it seems like you could do something
very similar to what we saw with the
with the actual ether it could donate an
electron it could make it could donate
an electron to this bond right over here
in which case you would have a resonance
structure that looks like this and if it
donates an electron to this carbon over
here then an electron can be taken away
from the carbon and given back to that
oxygen so that would give us a resonance
structure that would look like this
it would give us a resonance structure
that guy now has a negative charge we
now have a double bond to this oxygen it
still has another bond to the other acyl
group just like that and now this oxygen
gave away an electron so it has a
positive charge so it seems like a very
similar situation to what we saw with an
ether but there's another resonance
structure here you could also have a
situation where instead of
instead of the electron being donated to
this carbon bond and that happening you
could have a situation like this where
the electron gets donated to that carbon
bond and then this electron gets taken
back by that oxygen so you would have
you would have this situation
you would have a situation
where this is still this acyl group
still looks the same bonded this oxygen
but now we have a double bond over here
this guy took away an electron so one of
the double bond one of the bonds in the
double bonds goes away now has a
negative charge and then you have the
rest of the molecule so you actually
have these two resonance structures so
the and of course this is now a positive
charge since it gave away an electron so
you might say hey more resonance
structures more stability but the key
here is to realize is that both
resonance structures are dependent from
the same oxygen this they essentially
have to share this oxygen's electrons so
each one of these individually is less
likely to occur than just what occurs
with the ether this guy's you could kind
of view it as that both of these bonds
have to share what in the ether this one
gets it on its own and we even saw that
this is still less likely to occur than
this over here so either so in this
situation it is an anhydride if one guy
is getting the double bond the other
guys the if there's a resonance
structure on one side of the anhydride
the other side is still reactive if
there's a resonance structure on on the
left side then the right side is still
reactive so we'll call this less stable
this right here is less stable
less stable and then finally you have
your acetyl chloride and acetyl chloride
there really is no resonance structure
here chlorine is so electronegative that
it is unlikely to give away an electron
it it is sitting pretty it has no well
it i don't want to put it it is sitting
pretty with eight electrons that's
actually true for these other characters
right here but chlorine is very very
unlikely to contribute a resonance
structure here so this gets no stability
so this is the least stable
this is the least stable
of the carboxylic acid derivatives that
we're looking at now why am i even
bothering with all of this you know this
hierarchy of stability for carboxylic
acid derivatives and i'm bothering with
it is because we know or we don't know
quite yet but i've already shown you
some mechanisms that can take us from a
carboxylic acid to an ether or
carboxylic acid to an acyl halide and in
general you can go between all of these
and a carboxylic acid but since we know
their relative stabilities we know that
if you start with an acetyl chloride
you're much more likely to go to an
acetamide if you have the proper
ingredients there if you have some
amines floating around then the other
way around you're much more likely to go
from that to that because this is much
less stable than that than you are from
to go from acetamine to acetyl chloride
likewise you're much more likely to go
from a carboxylic acid to and or let me
put it this way you're much more likely
to go from a carboxylic acid to an
acetamide and i don't haven't drawn the
carboxylic acid here but this has better
resonance than even its original
carboxylic acid than the other way
around or you're much more likely to go
from an anhydride to an ether so that's
why i'm doing this hierarchy you're much
more likely to go from something on the
right to something on the left and we'll
explore some of those mechanisms in the
next few videos